welcome back to cbs saturday morning it
was the blockbuster deal that had the
internet buzzing but questions remain
this weekend about elon musk's proposed
takeover of twitter the world's
wealthiest man made his 44 billion offer
six weeks ago but the deal has hit some
snags including threats by musk to back
out it's all sent speculation on the
future of the social media platform on a
wild ride
john blackstone takes us through from
san francisco
elon musk's complicated relationship
with twitter and with fake twitter
accounts stretches back at least 12
years in 2010 with others on twitter
claiming to be him
at elon musk made what was apparently
his first entry on the site saying
please ignore prior tweets as that was
someone pretending to be me
in the years since musk has amassed some
90 million followers on twitter only
barack obama and a handful of superstars
in music and one in soccer have more but
no one else in that twitter elite is
capable of shaking up the stock market
the way musk can i would characterize
this behavior as
being very uncontrolled attorney
anne-marie murphy is part of a team of
attorneys who have filed a civil lawsuit
accusing musk of market manipulation at
the expense of twitter shareholders i
think it's it's just absolutely
offensive i think he referred to himself
possibly as a toddler once i mean it
feels like a young child run amok beyond
caring about their personal billions and
maybe not i don't know you know caring
or realizing the impacts on everyday
americans
since early may musk has made a chart of
twitter's share price look like a
recording of earthquake aftershocks the
first of those shocks hit the market on
april 4th with twitter rising more than
28 percent
after musk revealed he'd acquired nine
percent of the company's stock the price
rose further on april 25th when musk
agreed to buy twitter for 44 billion
dollars there was an announcement that
the um that mr musk was going to
purchase twitter and shareholders were
to be paid 54.20 a share
the market responded positively to that
that news but on may 13th twitter shares
plunged 25
after musk tweeted the deal is
temporarily on hold
the price dropped further on may 17th
with another musk tweet the deal cannot
move forward he said until the company
proves only five percent of twitter
users are fake his mood seems to change
from day to day on twitter and those
changing tweets can attract the
attention of financial regulators says
mark fagal now retired from the
securities exchange commission and i
think what the sec is struggling with is
they're really limited to bringing cases
where there is fraud where you are
making a demonstrably false statement
that's material meaning it's important
to investors if you
have a tweet a few hundred letters
talking about your whim that moment i
like twitter maybe i'm less excited
about buying twitter is that false
that's hard the sec is investigating
whether musk failed to disclose within
10 days as required that he owned more
than 5 percent of twitter and the sec
has gone after musk previously for one
of his tweets
in august 2018 he posted this and
considering taking tesla private at 4 20
funding secured
an sec investigation alleged that the
tweet lacked an adequate basis in fact
what did it cost him well he ended up
settling shortly thereafter so he paid
20 million dollars as a penalty now that
the world has so many billionaires
does the sec have enough punishment
available when elon musk can be fined 20
million dollars that's not very much for
the world's richest man is it it's a
real frustration penalties that the sec
can assess are fixed by law
and when they're dealing with
individuals or companies wall street
players with billions or trillions of
dollars at their disposal the current
penalties are not going to deter
somebody over the years musk has tweeted
about twitter many times in 2017 he said
simply i love twitter a few months later
he warned his followers don't take my
tweet too seriously for one thing it's
called a tweet but those suing musk are
taking his tweets about twitter very
seriously i think the hope would be that
mr musk completes the transaction on the
terms that he agreed to neither twitter
nor attorneys for elon musk responded to
our request for comment
if musk fails to buy twitter he could be
forced to pay a billion dollar breakup
fee
but that would still leave him a 200
billion dollar fortune
and of course he would still be able to
tweet for cbs saturday morning john
blackstone san francisco
it's always the hit him in the wallet
you can't hit somebody but you hit that
in the wallet right a a 20 million
dollar fine is like let's take 50 bucks
from you right even a billion yeah yeah
but elon musk you know a lot of
questions over what will happen if he
does take over the company specifically
with respect to language
on the platform abusive language and
already i i i would urge everyone to
take a look at um
dan patterson uh he has a report out on
just how abusive it still is on twitter
so it's you know a lot of people are
concerned specifically against
vice president kamala harris so it'll be
really interesting to see what happens